[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde sobriété entre croissance et
décroissance alors sobriété croissance
d'abord un oxymore quasiment une
contradiction à l'aune duant en vue de
réduire les consommations individuelles
tout en déployant un agenda national de
production
sobriété et décroissance un défi social
en même temps qu'un pari idéologique et
lyrique la sobre
ivresse de la vie selon Yvan Ilitch
l'apôtre inspiré de la décroissance si
croissance et décroissance s'opposent
terme à terme en vue de reconfigurer
l'État providence l'économie de marché
les modes de vie la démographie le
progrès et la science il en est
différemment avec la sobriété évoquée
sans discernement alors s'agit-il d'un
simple mot valise
l'espèce de fourre-tout conceptuel a
polarité positive quand il s'agit
d'éviter tous les gaspillage à même de
porter atteinte au climat à la
biodiversité à la finitude de certaines
ressources à l'obésité consumériste des
individus ou s'agit-il d'un trompe
l'oeil politique quand il est question
d'arbitrer les pénuries par
l'exhortation à de petits gestes
individuels et de repousser au calendes
grec la persistance des inégalités
sociales chez nous comme plus gravement
dans les pays du Sud en quête de
développement et de rattrapage pour
mieux s'inscrire dans la mondialisation
alors vous l'avez compris nous allons
traiter d'un sujet qui est autant
politique que polémique autant
socio-économiques qu'axiologiques c'est
à dire dépendante des valeurs et
notamment des valeurs de liberté de
démocratie de solidarité pour en parler
je signale que nous sommes en
visio-conférence avec Monsieur Boris
Ravignon qui est président de l'ADEME et
maire de Charleville-Mézières bonjour
monsieur Ravignon bonjour monsieur
je rappelle que vous êtes architecte
urbaniste général de l'État et
secrétaire permanente duplucca bonjour
Monsieur Olivier luizy je vous êtes
spécialiste de l'industrie à PwC bonjour
Louis Gallois vous êtes qu'aux président
de la fabrique de l'industrie ancien
président d'Airbus et de la SNCF et
bonjour madame barbara Pompili vous êtes
député de la Somme vous êtes ancienne
ministre de la transition écologique
[Musique]
vous avez vu la citation de Monsieur
Castoriadis et cette imaginaire
capitaliste qui va dans le sens de la
croissance et du développement est-ce
que vous pensez possible aujourd'hui une
reconversion écologique de notre
économie qui viendrait enserrer la
croissance dans des contraintes
environnementales et sociales vous
voulez commencer monsieur Avignon
alors volontiers volontiers parce que je
crois que ce sujet que vous évoquez là
c'est un sujet qui est vraiment au cœur
des travaux de prospective de l'ADEME
que je préside maintenant de pays depuis
quelques semaines donc je j'ai pris
connaissance de manière assez
approfondie de des travaux que nous que
nous publions que publie l'agence et
notamment celui qui s'appelle transition
2050 où on essaie de imaginer les
différents scénarios qui vont nous
permettre d'atteindre la décarbonation
de l'économie de et de notre société
donc la neutralité carbone à l'échelle à
l'horizon 2050 avec ses l'une des
conditions du respect des engagements de
l'accord de Paris et cette eh bien ce
cet objectif là on a plusieurs moyens de
l'atteindre et c'est je crois la grande
valeur ajoutée des travaux de l'ADEME
d'avoir imaginé plusieurs scénarios l'un
extrêmement sobre où on va jusqu'à
diminuer par deux la consommation
d'énergie et puis
un autre à l'autre poser le scénario 4
qui lui va laisse finalement dériver la
consommation d'énergie puis des
scénarios où il y a une composante de
sobriété variable et bien la ce que on
constate dans dans ces modèles et la
dame a absolument tenu à modéliser un
certain nombre de paramètres
macroéconomiques sur le sur la
croissance sur l'emploi sur le la
balance commerciale c'est que nous
pouvons effectivement atteindre cette
neutralité carbone et qu'aucun des
scénarios que nous avons retenu et bien
ne prévoit une récession par rapport au
niveau d'activité d'aujourd'hui
ne prévoit pas une récession de c'est à
dire une chute de la croissance
effectivement on peut faire de la
sobriété tout en ayant de la croissance
c'est ce que vous dites c'est ce qu'on
c'est ce que les modèles effectivement
produisent et alors ces modèles ce
modèle ils ont il est il est
naturellement dans les anticipations il
a fait l'objet d'une analyse assez
approfondie
par ce Pisani ferry il y a encore
quelques quelques mois et on a je crois
une assez grande confiance dans le fait
que aujourd'hui effectivement le fait de
remplacer les énergies fossiles par des
énergies renouvelables de diminuer c'est
prévu effectivement dans sur ces
trajectoires la consommation d'un
certain nombre de bien manufacturés
d'importation pour les remplacer par les
consommations plus locales par des par
aussi pas une consommation de service
qui sont davantage produit localement
mais aussi un des trajectoires dans
lesquels on investit énormément dans une
meilleure efficacité énergétique de nos
bâtiments qui au niveau spécialement des
prix de l'énergie que nous connaissons à
un véritable rendement économique
c'est-à-dire que on non seulement on
rembourse le capital qu'on emprunte
quand on quand on fait des travaux
d'isolation sur le bâti mais on dégage
du revenu supplémentaire donc on a je
crois les éléments effectivement non
seulement de d'un modèle de transition
écologique où on gagne on sobriété en
efficacité énergétique où on atteint nos
objectifs écologiques mais où on ne
dégrade pas la situation macroéconomique
et au contraire on continue à avoir une
progression de la richesse alors on vous
a entendu monsieur Ravignon alors madame
Pompili vous avez été ministre de la
transition écologique alors ça change
des fois ces transitions énergétiques
écologiques en tout cas vous avez été
peut-être pensante de l'écologie dans un
gouvernement de la majorité avec
Monsieur Macron comme président pour
vous c'est possible d'en serrer la
croissance dans des contraintes
écologiques
je suis interpellé par la manière dont
vous posez la question en fait parce que
vous dites enserrer vous dites
contraintes donc déjà vous mettez
quelque part même un jugement de valeur
transition écologique la transition
écologique ça nécessite effectivement de
se projeter et d'essayer d'apporter face
à un état des lieux du monde dans lequel
nous vivons aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de solutions et je pense que
Monsieur Avignon a expliqué très
clairement que les outils existent c'est
pas une question d'outils en fait on a
les outils mais je crois profondément
pour avoir exercé des fonctions qui
m'ont permis de toucher du doigt le
problème que on ne peut mettre en place
tous ces outils que si on réussit à
raconter un récit un récit de ce qu'on
veut construire quand vous dites
contraintes et quand vous dites en serré
vous présentez la transition écologique
comme quelque part l'adaptation à
quelque chose qui nous tombe dessus et
qui est quelque chose de négatif on va
rentrer dans le débat mais vous verrez
qu'il faudra consommer moins d'énergie
vous consommez moins d'eau etc donc ce
sont des contraintes parce que oui mais
la en société est une vie qui est
composée de contraintes nous avons des
lois nous avons des règles et c'est
marrant parce que quand il s'agit
d'écologie ce sont des contraintes c'est
difficile or simplement ce sont des
règles de vie en commun ce que je trouve
très intéressant dans ce que nous vivons
actuellement c'est que nous sommes
obligés ça c'est vrai de réinterroger le
monde dans lequel nous vivons et les
valeurs qui sont des valeurs que nous
avons portées pendant des années est-ce
que le monde Anthon nous vivons est un
monde souhaitable et un monde heureux
moi je trouve que c'est passionnant et
je pense que on ne peut entraîner tout
le monde dans justement effectivement
des changements
en leur expliquant vers où on veut aller
et aujourd'hui je trouve que c'est ce
qui manque on va trop vite vers l'outil
sans expliquer que on peut construire un
monde dans lequel on peut être mieux
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas parce que on
achète deux fois moins de pull qu'on
sera moins bien chauffé ou qu'on soit on
sera moins heureux et c'est pas parce
que on a une voiture qui sera moins
grosse et qui est avec un autre moteur
qu'on sera moins heureux c'est pas parce
que on prend
vision
écologiste ou écologique la question que
je vous pose est plus simple que ça et
sans jugement de valeur c'est de savoir
si en respectant
toutes ces que vous appelez ça d'énormes
des contraintes ou que vous appelez ça
simplement pour vous une nécessité
est-ce qu'on arrivera à maintenir la
croissance du pays voilà c'est tout
c'est pas plus que ça oui mais est-ce
qu'on arrivera à contenir à maintenir la
croissance du pays la croissance est
dans étant donc la rentrée dans le
détail
je vous pose simplement la question je
vous dis simplement que et c'était des
grands exemples qu'on sortait depuis
longtemps que une guerre booste très
fort le taux de croissance d'un pays
donc est-ce que c'est forcément cela
qu'on veut obtenir moi je n'ai jamais
été de ces gens qui poussaient pour la
décroissance totale je pense que on peut
avoir un développement équilibré
économique on va rentrer on va rentrer
dans le détail que par exemple la
sobriété peut paradoxalement entraîner
une hausse du PIB puisque vous allez
avoir beaucoup d'emplois qui vont être
créés par exemple dans la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments parce qu'on
peut créer de nouvelles filières
économiques parce que donc la réponse
simplement à votre question et oui mais
il me semble que on va avoir un peu de
temps pour développer parce que tout à
fait on va rentrer dans le détail alors
Louis Gallois par rapport à la question
posée
qu'est-ce que vous dites moi je crois
que la décroissance est un
est un véritable risque sous deux
aspects la remise en cause du de
l'État-providence puisqu'on aurait pu
les ressources pour le financer ou alors
il faudrait être extrêmement coercitif
sur la réduction des inégalités avec un
cadeau un gâteau qui se rétrécit et
deuxièmement on a besoin de croissance
pour financer les énormes
investissements que va susciter la
transition énergétique en particulier
attention écologique en général mais la
transition énergétique en particulier et
donc la question se pose peut y avoir
une croissance verte comme on dit il y a
un débat là-dessus
c'est que oui mais il y a quatre
conditions la première c'est qu'il faut
un effort de recherche considérable
parce que certains de solutions seront
technologiques et supposent des franchir
des étapes le stockage de l'énergie on
en est pas encore là par exemple
toutes les les plastiques biodégradables
tous ces éléments je pourrais en citer
une dizaine
suppose un effort de recherche
considérable second élément c'est qu'il
faut que l'industrie modifie ses process
pour les décarboner il faut qu'elle
décarbonate ses process ça va coûter
énormément d'argent et ça n'a pas de
rentabilité pour les industriels qui
vont le faire donc il faut trouver
comment
justifier ses investissements du point
de vue des industriels qui vont avoir le
faire et qui faisant ces investissements
ne pourront pas en faire d'autres
troisième condition c'est qu'on soit
présent sur les nouveaux marchés les
nouvelles opportunités qui se présentent
sur grâce à la croissance verte vous
avez cité les matériaux les matériaux
isolants
je peux vous citer la viande végétale on
peut citer évidemment tout ce qui
concerne la production industrielle
d'énergie je reviendrai sur ce point
les voitures les batteries etc sur ces
marchés il faut se positionner c'est pas
du tout évident
mais vous croyez une croissance ouverte
vous venez de le sommet on va les
consommer ces produits et le fait qu'il
soit fabriqué en France c'est pas du
tout évident on l'a vu pour les panneaux
solaires ils sont fabriquent pas un en
France et nous importons 100% des
panneaux solaires et nous sommes pas
loin de le faire sur les éoliennes alors
la quatrième condition et pour tout cela
ce qu'il faut une énergie décarbonée
c'est qu'il faut une production
électrique qui devrait être nettement en
progression puisque l'électricité qui
représente à peu près 25% du mix
énergétique actuellement va représenter
en 2050 50 % du micellaire j'ai dit même
si on consomme moins d'énergie on va
consommer plus d'électricité il faut
produire cette électricité et je pense
que c'est un point tout à fait clé sur
lequel vous êtes d'accord tous pour
considérer que la chose est possible
mais dès lors que
l'aménagement puisse l'aménagement
puisse se faire alors allons essayons
d'aller un peu plus loin là-dessus
madame pesquit on sort d'une crise
sanitaire nous sommes confrontés à la
guerre en Ukraine les conséquences
économiques sont devant nous
rareté on l'a vu de certaines sources
énergétiques les prix au flambé ne
parlons pas de l'électricité
c'est imposer cette notion de sobriété
énergétique aujourd'hui pourquoi pas de
toute manière les gens sont obligés de
l'accepter et les résultats sont là
puisque les citoyens se sont montrés
citoyens mais alors la question qui se
pose
l'industrie mais aussi les particuliers
Louis particulier
la question que je voudrais vous poser
c'est tous ces gestes individuels que
l'on demande aux personnes de sobriété
c'est une chose mais en même temps la
machine économique et industrielle
s'emploie tournée à plein régime
c'est-à-dire que il y a de choses et ce
qui a pas ici une contradiction dans les
termes et même dans les intentions
je voudrais dire trois choses peut-être
sur ce point d'abord
je pense que c'est plutôt finalement
salutaire qu'on a expérimenté tous
collectivement dans le monde entier une
sobriété obligatoire une contrainte très
forte sur l'approvisionnement pendant la
crise sanitaire et puis de nouveau sur
certains approvisionnements notamment en
céréales et en énergie depuis la crise
en Ukraine et je pense que finalement ce
signal prix qui est le signal le plus
efficace pour apprendre à être plus
sobre et à reconnaître finalement de
quoi on a besoin pour fonctionner c'est
un apprentissage accéléré qui est
certainement à mon avis qui est bon pour
la société c'est à dire qu'on se rend
beaucoup mieux compte de quoi on dépend
et en réalité on dépend de
individuellement de beaucoup de choses
les collectivités locales et territoires
dépendent aussi évidemment de ressources
très nombreuses et très variées avec des
origines très diverses et évidemment
l'état la nation les entreprises chacun
dépend d'un certain nombre de ressources
dont on ne mesurait peut-être pas
avancer de grandes crises à quel point
elles étaient pas sûr que les gens
soient plus heureux de payer beaucoup
plus cher leur électricité en tout cas
c'est une expérience suffisamment forte
pour qu'elle fasse réfléchir et qu'elle
fasse prendre conscience d'enjeux qu'on
avait évidemment dans le contexte
politique déjà évoqué mais qui était
peut-être pas aussi fortement voilà
intégré par les gens individuellement et
collectivement je le redis c'est vrai
autant pour les collectivités locales
qui payent très cher donc leur énergie
aujourd'hui aussi que pour les
entreprises que pour les individus
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
qu'on a tendance à réduire la sobrule la
notion de sobriété ou l'ambition de
sobriété à la propriété énergétique or
on a expérimenté encore l'été dernier
d'autres pénuries que celle de l'énergie
donc notamment des problèmes de
sécheresse extrêmement important l'été
dernier
pompier qui s'occupe de la gouvernance
de l'eau pour en parler mieux que moi
mais en tout cas on va devoir aussi
apprendre à gérer d'autres types de
pénurie et donc d'autres formules de
sobriété notamment sur l'eau sur les
matières premières moi je m'intéresse à
la ville à la construction on va bientôt
manquer de sable pour le béton on voit
bien que en fait cette difficulté à
d'approvisionner devant nous elle est de
plus en plus forte et donc il faudra
mettre en place effectivement des
régulations de l'approvisionnement et le
troisième point c'est qu'on ne doit pas
je pense non plus réduire cette idée de
contrat sur les petits gestes aux
individus en fait en réalité je disais
pour les collectivités locales
cette politique de sobriété elle
s'applique à tout décideurs qui sont
individuels ou collectifs notamment aux
décideurs territoriaux évidemment aux
entreprises qui on l'a vu pendant
l'automne ont évidemment transformé leur
process industriel voir fermer un
certain nombre de chaînes de production
et donc il y a aussi sont en train de se
poser la question de leur process
industriel donc cette notion de sobriété
elle n'est pas rapportée à mon avis
qu'aux individus et aux petits gestes et
elle est bien une question de
transformation de la manière dont la
société
se fait face à son modèle économique
je reste sur ma question
est-ce que vous voyez pas une
contradiction entre ces gestes
individuels qui sont demandés aux
individus et en même temps
la nécessité
de développer l'outil économique de
production française
en insiste beaucoup pour qu'il y ait une
réindustrialisation parler de tout ça en
demandant des gestes de sobriété à des
individus est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose
à harmoniser entre les deux c'est pas là
que je verrai la contradiction par
contre est-ce qu'il y a un manque de
cohérence globale et de direction oui je
reprends ce que disait madame Pompili
c'est il faudrait qu'on ait un projet
sur lequel on se raccroche on a eu un
projet de société qui était autour de
l'équipement de la consommation qui a
même dérivé à la consommation de masse
et derrière parce qu'il y avait une
demande on a fait un outil de productif
de masse avec toutes les prévarications
qu'il a pu avoir sur l'environnement et
le fait qu'aujourd'hui on atteint un
certain nombre de limites ce modèle est
dépassé on est en train de basculer vers
un autre projet de société qui n'est pas
encore pleinement définie et c'est sans
doute la première brique sur laquelle il
faut qu'on travaille collectivement on a
plusieurs défis on parle de la sobriété
aujourd'hui on peut aussi parler de la
souveraineté vous l'avez quelque part
évoqué entre les deux il y a des
injonctions contradictoires et donc il
va falloir que collectivement nous
commencions à donner une direction un
peu ferme qui nous permettent en tous
les cas de définir quel outil productif
on veut un outil productif de
souveraineté par exemple ça va demander
d'ouvrir des mines en France est-ce
qu'on y est prêt alors que on voudrait
préserver l'espace naturel entre les
deux comment on choisit mais ça le choix
on n'a pas d'instance on va ouvrir une
mine naturelle c'est pas des
visages et le paysage français
demander aux personnes qui vivent à côté
regardez les difficultés qui peut y
avoir et encore une fois je je pense
qu'il va falloir réexploiter les
richesses qu'on a dans notre sous-sol
donc je pense que c'est une direction
qu'on doit prendre mais demander aux
personnes qui vivent à côté de ces sites
comment ils le vivent et on doit avoir
cette obligation d'écouter les
territoires d'écouter des citoyens qui
vivent pour leurs qualités de vie la
façon dont on le fait donc le premier
point c'est vraiment quel est notre
projet collectif vers quoi on se
projette et ça c'est quelque chose
autour de la sobriété de la circularité
on voit quelques mots un bout de
souveraineté aussi mais on n'a pas tout
à fait et puis à partir du moment on
aura ça quelque part il sera
relativement facile de définir quel est
l'outil productif qui va avec qui sera
certainement beaucoup plus sobre je
pense que le mot clé qui va émerger
c'est celui de circularité entre nous
enfin voilà si je devais donner un pari
c'est celui de circularité et qu'est-ce
que vous mettez dans cette circularité
l'entièreté notamment des matières
premières et le fait d'être capable de
reprendre un produit le recyclage
matière est en quasiment l'ultime
solution mais la réparabilité la
récupération des pièces la démontabilité
seront absolument clés dans tous les
objets du quotidien qu'on va avoir
autour de nous demain donc l'industrie
et notamment enfin tout ce qui produit
nos objets cette chaise des livres nos
stylos nos smartphones est en face d'un
défi dont on connaît pas exactement la
direction mais qu'on sent bien qui est
celle de réinventer tous les produits et
là on n'a pas encore tout à fait des
solutions on ne sait pas encore faire la
circularité c'est extrêmement compliqué
de tous les produits qui sont autour de
nous mais c'est un défi fantastique
est-ce qu'il va être créateur d'activité
ou pas je pense qu'il faut bien
réfléchir à ce qui s'est passé par
exemple sur la voiture on passait d'une
motorisation thermique on est passé à
une motorisation enfin la décision d'une
autorisation électrique c'est une
décision qui a été politique dans le
sens où elle est symbolique on a dit
2035 terminé quand on regarde les études
il faut un peu discernement il y a des
cas où l'usage de la voiture électrique
n'est pas le meilleur pour
l'environnement il y a des cas où il
l'est donc la première leçon de ça c'est
que dans les décisions qui va falloir
prendre il va falloir mettre du
discernement et pas que du symbole et ça
on a un peu du mal à le faire
collectivement le deuxième élément qui
est derrière c'est quand on a lancé
cette transition assez rapide on sait
pas réellement occupé de toute la
filière 100 000 emplois en France qui
sont concernés est-ce qu'on s'est occupé
de leur transformation est-ce qu'on veut
un modèle de société ou c'est le marché
tu vas faire cette adaptation ou bien
c'est la puissance publique qui compagne
donc on a aujourd'hui sans répondre à
votre question tout à fait sur
croissance on a un véritable enjeu quel
est notre projet quelle est la façon
dont on va faire les produits qui vont
servir ce projet de société et comment
on organise la troupe on vous a entendu
là-dessus alors
madame Pompili sur cette dualité entre
l'individu d'un côté et la collectivité
de l'autre est-ce qu'il y a vous qui
êtes une politique est-ce qu'il y a pas
un travail pédagogique à faire pour que
les gens comprennent que les efforts
qu'on leur demande
doivent être si je puis dire à la mesure
de ce que le pouvoir politique peut
faire pour transformer globalement tout
le processus mais c'est un point central
et je rejoins ce que vous disiez on a
besoin d'un récit pour dire à tout le
monde vers où on veut aller
parce que si on n'a pas ce récit là vous
allez avoir des réactions qui sont des
réactions qu'on voit aujourd'hui qui
sont des réactions de peur d'inquiétude
face à l'avenir où on ne voit que les
contraintes justement et où on n'arrive
pas à se projeter ça entraîne des
manifestations dont la plus emblématique
était celle des gilets jaunes qui qui a
bien montré que une partie de la
population aujourd'hui a le sentiment
que le monde avance sans elle et on peut
d'ailleurs retranscrire ça au niveau
mondial on a aussi un certain nombre de
pays qui ont l'impression que le monde
avance sans eux et qui du coup ne se
sentent pas partie prenante de cette
transition on ne réussira pas à faire ce
qu'on veut faire quand bien même on
trouverait tous les outils si on n'a pas
cette adhésion au futur qu'on veut
construire et en plus se rajoute à cela
la complexité que nous sommes dans un
monde ouvert et que on ne peut plus
réfléchir à ces solutions uniquement au
niveau national ou même au niveau
régional on a besoin d'avoir une
visibilité et d'avoir un travail que que
l'on fait au niveau continental
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que le
gouvernement fait ce que vous dites
le gouvernement actuel
une insuffisance de pédagogie je sais
que c'est difficile de critiquer ces
successeurs partout mais bon est-ce que
en plus c'est un travail de long terme
qui a été mise en place par le
gouvernement c'est le fait de
décider d'avoir un organisme accolé à la
première ministre qui en charge de la
planification pourquoi parce que ça
oblige quelque part tout le monde à
prendre je vais employer le terme de
charge mentale à prendre la charge
mentale de la transition écologique qui
avant était quand même laissé aux soins
du ministre en charge de l'environnement
on va dire ça comme ça moi je l'ai vécu
même s'il y a beaucoup d'efforts qui
avaient été faits
qui en charge ne soit pas un écologiste
par exemple je n'appartiennent pas
disons un parti écologiste
non à partir du moment où tout le monde
prend
en compte cette
ce point moi ce qui me gêne un petit peu
c'est que on a aussi des gens qui ont
une culture qui ont pas vraiment une
culture écologiste et qui ont simplement
une conscience que on a un objet qui est
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qui sont trop importantes et qu'il faut
réduire et donc on a face à ça des gens
qui réfléchissent à des outils pour
faire pour réduire ses émissions de gaz
à effet de serre mais ça c'est très
important mais c'est insuffisant à mon
sens si on veut avoir un récit collectif
encore une fois qui est la base tout le
travail on a pu vous entendez je voulais
rebondir sur ce que disait olivier est
lancée à l'instant sur la nécessité de
relocaliser l'industrie qui pourrait
être en contradiction avec cette logique
de sobriété prenez par le pouvoir en
place mais en fait je crois qu'il faut
arrêter de penser que que sobriété
croissance sont totalement divergentes
je pense qu'il y a aujourd'hui on en a
fait la preuve que des politiques de
sobriété en tout cas d'efficacité
énergétique d'économie de matière
d'économie d'énergie son créatrice
d'emploi d'abord on l'indique sur la
rénovation des bâtiments par exemple
c'est une activité une stratégie une
politique publique qui est créatrice
d'emploi dans le bâtiment on le voit
justement on parlait de relocalisation
de mine on vient d'ouvrir une mine de
lithium en Auvergne dans l'ancien
bassinier les gens sont plutôt
satisfaits ou en tout cas le territoire
accueille plutôt favorablement cette
ouverture 2000 c'est pas toujours vrai
mais plutôt favorablement dans le sens
où ça redonne une activité une autre
activité économique à un bassin d'emploi
qui était plutôt en déprime donc on voit
quand même que sous réserve de
comprendre dans quel monde on se situe
et pourquoi cette relocalisation est
bénéfique aussi à l'environnement au
sens où on va diminuer la distance
parcourue par les matières premières on
arrive à créer du positif avec un récit
qui a priori est plutôt reçu
négativement donc il y a effectivement
besoin de d'exemples très concrets pour
expliquer comment on crée de la j'aime
pas trop dire de la croissance mais en
tout cas de la richesse et une forme de
prospérité à partir de politique qui
vise à réduire à la fois nos dépendances
de dépendance c'est des kilomètres
parcourus donc c'est du carbone émis
dans l'atmosphère et notre voilà et
améliorer notre capacité à être
suffisant un nombre de domaines
économiques monsieur Boris Ravignon je
voulais intervenir là-dessus mais je
voudrais également que vous interveniez
sur le point que je vous suggère
est-ce que votre avis sans signal prix
c'est à dire une vraie
taxation du carbone
est-ce qu'on est pas réduire à faire du
bricolage écologique
alors permettrait je vous réponds juste
dans la foulée je voulais simplement
réagir au débat pour dire que on le voit
bien c'est d'ailleurs un peu le aussi le
thème de votre de notre
émission d'aujourd'hui c'est il y a une
forme déco anxiété aujourd'hui une
inquiétude sur à la fois l'évolution
écologique planète dégradation et le
changement climatique et tout ce qui est
implique et puis
l'inquiétude sur les voix les
trajectoires les moyens les Pau par
lesquels passer pour atteindre les
objectifs pour agir finalement et et
aller vers vers cette vers une
amélioration de de la situation et donc
je crois quand même alors on peut
toujours effectivement trouver le verre
à moitié vide mais qu'un certain
d'outils commencent maintenant à être en
place que sur le fait par exemple de
programmer de planifier les une
évolution et on parle pas de petites
évolutions je prends juste un exemple si
vous le permettez on a on sait que on
doit pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050 faire que 90%
des logements des 30 millions de
logements que nous avons il y a 37
millions de logements rien que ça se
trouve en 2050 avec des niveaux de
consommation qui sont ceux du bébé C
donc c'est un niveau extrêmement
exigeant c'est presque divisé par 3 la
consommation moyenne des logements par
mètre carré donc il y a pour faire ce
travail là il faut qu'on passe de 41000
rénovations BBC qu'on a fait sur la
période récente à 700 000 alors
accessoirement ça va créer pas mal
d'emplois ça va mais mais effectivement
ça requiert des investissements et bien
aujourd'hui on commence à avoir sur les
demandes en France 2030 dans le dans les
politiques qui sont conduites des moyens
pour accompagner ces investissements ces
investissements qui sont à la différence
de ce dont parlait Louis Gallois tout à
l'heure pour les une partie de se
désindustriels des investissements
rentables d'investissement qui quand on
vont être faits vont au bout du compte
dégager du revenu pour les pour les
locataires ils vont une fois qu'ils ont
remboursé leur prêts se trouvait mieux
dans un logement mieux isolé et puis on
commence à mettre en place aussi les les
moyens destinés à la décarbonation de
l'industrie ça a été rappelé c'est
crucial la moitié de France 2030 des 54
milliards de France 2030 et consacré à
la décarbonation de notre économie donc
les outils sont là mais c'est vrai et je
rejoins ce qui a été dit par Hélène
pesquine et barbara Pompili et on a
besoin aussi que les représentations
évoluent si le fait de parce que le le
prix du carburant c'est un peu une
réponse aussi à ce que ce que la
question que vous posiez sur le sur les
prix de l'énergie si vous fait le prix
du carburant vous incite à prendre votre
vélo plutôt que votre voiture vous le
vivez comme la le finalement une
déchéance totale vous n'êtes plus
capable de transporter votre SUV une
tonne et demi sur 300 ou 400 mètres pour
aller chercher la baguette de pain et
vous êtes obligé de prendre votre vélo
si vous le vivez comme ça effectivement
le récit qu'on a de cette de ce
moment-là c'est une contrainte terrible
qui m'oblige à faire quelque chose
d'extrêmement désagréable si en réalité
vous vous inscrivez dans le
développement d'une du du finalement de
l'utilisation du vélo au quotidien qui
est à la fois à des vertus écologiques
économiques parce que ça coûte quand
même beaucoup moins cher que de
transporter des tonnes de métal pour des
toutes petites distances qu'on peut
faire beaucoup plus légèrement et et
aussi meilleur à votre santé vous n'avez
pas exactement la même vision de cette
même expérience et donc ça effectivement
il faut faire rentrer si je puis dire
des sous dans la caisse est-ce que sans
une taxation du carbone mais qui soit
une véritable taxation on peut réussir
parce que ça met du temps vous le savez
bien pour le nouveau là je crois ça a
été dit par d'autres intervenants mais
la hausse prodigieuse des prix de
l'énergie qu'on vient de connaître ah je
crois permis de franchir un certain
nombre de cartes de sensibilisation et
on a aujourd'hui moi je peux vous le
dire je rencontre des artisans des chefs
d'entreprise et des ménages qui sont
extrêmement sensibles parce qu'ils ont
vu justement la hausse des prix de
l'énergie
ces derniers servaient à moi et sont et
sont en train de rechercher justement
les investissements qui vont leur
permettre d'être plus efficace et ils
sont en train de réfléchir à la sobriété
il y a des concepts qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à un peu à stabiliser
l'efficacité c'est quand vous changez
pas vos usages et vous allez simplement
une utilisation de l'équipe de l'énergie
de plus en plus d'électricité comme ça a
été dit qui qui est moindre vous arrivez
à finalement à améliorer le
fonctionnement du système énergétique et
puis la sobriété c'est de se dire est-ce
que pour vivre seul j'ai besoin de 186
mètres carrés
c'est ça et du coup effectivement un
certain nombre de le ménage d'acteurs
économiques ménage ou entreprise font
ses choix là et je crois qu'il y a pas
on me semble-t-il dans le contexte dans
lequel on est il y aurait pas vraiment
de nécessité de rajouter un signal prix
fiscal supplémentaire il me semble que
le
les prix de l'énergie tel qu'ils sont
ont déjà convaincu absolument tout le
monde de se mettre en mouvement merci
Monsieur Avignon je reviens vers vous
sur la taxation du carbone est-ce qu'il
faut pas vraiment avoir un prix
consolidé du carbone pour
réussir ses avancées écologiques si
évidemment évidemment on a besoin d'un
prix pour le carbone qui soit un juste
prix c'est-à-dire qui représente aussi
c'est quoi le juste prix la tonne ce
serait
il y a eu plusieurs projections qui ont
été faites
on était à 100 euros la tonne comme
objectif
ça avait été une trajectoire qui avait
été prévu par par les précédent
gouvernement ça a été stoppé net au
moment de la faire des gilets jaunes
mais tout le monde est assez d'accord
pour dire qu'on a besoin de mettre en
place une tarification une une taxation
du carbone qui permet d'ailleurs de
financer aussi des politiques de
transition écologique mais ça ça doit
aussi s'entendre j'insiste là-dessus
mais ça doit aussi s'entendre dans une
relation avec ce qu'on fait avec les
autres pays et parce que on est dans un
monde ouvert on est dans un monde où il
y a des échanges commerciaux avec le
monde entier et donc ça ne peut pas
s'entendre comme ça sans regarder les
conséquences que ça peut avoir sur nos
entreprises et sur et sur et sur nos
consommateurs quand l'Europe travaille
un mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières qui étaient portées pendant
très longtemps par la France et qui a
été enfin validé au niveau de l'Union
européenne c'est un grand pas vers une
taxation mondiale du carbone et en tout
cas vers une harmonisation des règles
aussi au niveau international sur cela
on ne pourra pas y arriver si on ne met
pas en place ce genre de mécanisme ça
fait réagir on voit bien qu'il y a des
réticences que ce soit les États-Unis
que ce soit la Chine mais des
expériences sont en train de se mettre
en place et je crois qu'on est en train
de mettre en place quelque chose de
vertueux de ce point de vue là merci
[Musique]
Louis Gallois nous sommes tous
favorables à des investissements dans
les biens communs
il s'agisse de l'eau l'énergie la santé
le logement l'éducation et autres
services publics notamment avec le
modèle social européen sincèrement
est-ce qu'il est possible de faire tous
ces investissements sans croissance
réponse évidemment c'est que non mais je
pense que
je
participe j'ai pas participé au débat
précédent
moi je pense on dit on va réciter une
sorte d'unanimité qui se présente
autour de cette
de ce cercle c'est uneanimité elle est
pas dans le pays
les problèmes
nous devons affronter les problèmes
est-ce que sur le
l'énergie par exemple on est d'accord
entre le nucléaire et l'on ouvre
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire sur le
nucléaire qu'est-ce que vous faire sur
le renouvelable est-ce que
vous parliez du prix de l'essence comme
un indicateur c'est très bien mais il va
falloir expliquer ça
aux gens qui au gilet jaune je pense que
notre émission il faut pas qu'elle soit
regarder par les gilets jaunes parce que
nous allons avoir des effets
sur je pense à un spectacle essayer de
prévenir les manifestations alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire je pense je
pense qu'on ne peut pas
établir un récit
où on intègre
les biens communs
les soirs indispensables sans faire des
choix qui soient claires pour le pays
et je pense que ces choix ne peuvent
être résultées que de travail
démocratique
menée avec beaucoup de soins et ensuite
une planification pour mettre en oeuvre
moi je suis désolé
de taxer le carbone très bien
mais en quoi ça bouge le rappeler on vit
pas dans le monde on vit dans un monde
ouvert je vous rappelle que la base
commerciale de la France c'est 150
milliards déficites et que 650 milliards
des visites c'est du carbone que nous
importons
et qui lui ne bénéficie aucune d'aucune
taxation alors on va mettre en place
justement carbone
je considère que c'est un geste
symbolique important je veux pas le nier
mais cette ajustement que vous êtes
favorable à cette agence il faut voir
comment se présente dans le détail on va
on va ajuster on va taxer l'acier brut
rentrant en Europe
très bien ça va faire que l'acier en
Europe soit produit par les européennes
soit importée va avoir plus cher
les constructeurs automobiles ils vont
les construire leur voiture à
l'extérieur de l'Europe pour avoir de la
si moins cher ils ont déjà commencé à le
faire assez largement ils vont
poursuivre est-ce qu'il faut taxer les
automobiles si on taxe des automobiles
ou grandit en se retrouvent à l'OMC
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce donc
je pense que on a affaire à des affaires
des sujets extrêmement complexes et qui
suppose des choix politiques assez
tranchées mais le fond de votre pensée
le rigalois
vous vous êtes fait le chantre de la
réindustrialisation bien sûr vous pensez
que c'est possible
en allant vers une transition écologique
tout à l'heure les conditions d'une
réindustrialisation c'est d'abord je
l'ai dit un effort de recherche c'est
ensuite que les process industriels
soient décarbonés et pour que ces
processus soit des carbonés il va
falloir que le pays et l'Europe
assurent les conditions de financement
de cette mémoire
mais les citoyens aujourd'hui vous
parlez des gilets jaunes c'est une chose
mais les citoyens aujourd'hui contestent
la notion de PNB comme seul indicateur
économique qui préfèrent ils préfèrent
aussi avoir un indicateur qui soit plus
sociable c'est très bien que les
indicateurs sociaux moi j'ai présidé une
fédération de lutte contre la pauvreté
j'ai quelques idées sur le sujet bon
alors pourquoi
on a besoin de de croissance financière
qui apporte de la ressource vous parlez
de financement de grandes
infrastructures on a besoin d'argent
pour cela donc moi je pense que ceux qui
plaident pour la décroissance
plaid pour un modèle social différent de
celui dans lequel nous vivons c'est à la
fin de l'étape vivant
en revanche si on veut financer
l'État-providence si on veut financer
les investissements que vous évoquez il
va falloir de la croissance et cette
croissance je répète c'est un de la
recherche de des process décarbonés 3 de
se positionner sur les industries
d'avenir qui sont industries qui qui
sont liées à la transition énergétique
et écologique et 4 c'est de produire de
l'électricité en masse parce qu'on
décarbonera pas si on n'a pas beaucoup
d'électricité ou si on veut décarboner
avec moins d'électricité on le fera en
important l'essentiel des produits donc
il nous faut de l'électricité pour
produire en Europe qu'est-ce que vous
dites barbara Pompili quand vous écoutez
un grand patron comme Louis Gallois dire
qu'on a besoin de croissance si on veut
financer les biens publics qui sont
requis par la communauté nationale je
pense que
c'est une vision que j'entends depuis
toujours
je suis d'accord sur le fait qu'il va
falloir investir beaucoup et que pour ça
il faut de l'argent et des moyens
maintenant on peut pas investir en ayant
en tête de faire comme avant
quand vous dites qu'il va falloir
beaucoup plus d'électricité je partage
et d'ailleurs maintenant toutes les
analyses la programmation plus réelle
d'énergie que vous avez
d'autres époque ne prévoyez pas une
augmentation de l'électricité ça date
d'avant 2015
ça date d'avant l'accord de Paris
s'adapte d'avant les objectifs de 2030
qui nous a fait fermer festenheim
vous parliez tout à l'heure de symboles
en voilà un symbole c'est c'est très
gentil de parler de symboles moi je
parle d'efficacité aujourd'hui nous
avons des objectifs de baisse des
missions de gaz à effet
on a tous collectivement essayez de
sortir de nos propres dogmes pour
essayer de regarder la situation en face
nous avons demandé d'avoir des rapports
avec des projections c'est RTE qui l'a
fait c'est l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie qui l'a fait negawat le fait
aussi avec ses propres avec ses propres
analyses qui ont toutes dit la même
chose qui ont dit nous avons nous allons
avoir besoin pour pouvoir baisser nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
plus d'électricité tout le monde est
d'accord là-dessus pour pouvoir faire
face à ses besoins les solutions sont
différentes selon les pays mais
concernant la France on va avoir besoin
de trois choses de trois choses monsieur
Gallois première chose développer
massivement les énergies renouvelables
beaucoup plus mais beaucoup plus de ce
que ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui donc ce
qui nécessite aussi beaucoup
d'investissement on va devoir encore se
fonder sur du nucléaire et là je rajoute
il faut quelques nouveaux réacteurs
parce que ce fonder uniquement sur les
réacteurs anciens de prendre un risque
qui est trop important à mon avis et
troisièmement troisièmement beaucoup de
sobriété et ce trépied là qui a été
proposé par le président Macron me
semble être le plus raisonnable et
réaliste dans la période actuelle
maintenant il faut qu'il y ait je vous
rejoins là-dessus un débat démocratique
pour valider tout ça ce débat
démocratique il est en cours il y a en
ce moment des consultations des citoyens
sur le sujet du programme global il va y
avoir une consultation par la CNDP sur
les nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires il va
y avoir et c'était une demande très
forte que nous avions exprimé quand
j'étais député avec d'autres une loi de
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
qui sera précédée d'un débat à
l'Assemblée nationale donc c'est à dire
dans le lieu clé de la démocratie de
notre pays pour pouvoir donner les
grandes orientations en tenant compte
évidemment de nos objectifs
Avignon là-dessus sur que
la politique énergétique qui a été menée
par le pays depuis 20 ans est une
politique totalement
erratique
mais je j'ai approuvé le discours de
Belfort j'ai pas de problème avec le
discours de Belfort je pense que nous
avons besoin d'énergie renouvelable je
trouve absolument scandaleux que l'Union
européenne nous accuse de ne pas avoir
atteint nos objectifs en énergie
renouvelables quand on voit l'énergie
des carbonées l'électricité des
carbonées en France par comparé à celle
de l'Allemagne en France nous avons
produit nous avons pris une électricité
avec 107
par kilowattheure les Allemands sont à
700 g et les Allemands se font encensés
par la commission parce qu'ils ont
développé les énergies renouvelables et
nous nous faisons accablés par la
commission vous montrer la très
clairement que les Allemands produisent
de l'énergie hyper carbonée et que la
Commission européenne ne dit rien et
d'ailleurs ce qui était ce qui était
paradoxaux
de midi c'est que la France était à 28%
de renouvelables et l'Allemagne à 29
c'est à dire que comme il n'y avait pas
de vent comme il y avait pas de soleil
et bien les ingrédients de la française
c'était de l'hydraulique et les énergies
renouvelables allemandes c'était de la
biomasse merci on va demander la vie de
Monsieur Avignon là-dessus sur ce débat
autour de la croissance qu'est ce que
vous en pensez je vais appuyé sur le là
encore sur les travaux qui sont les
travaux de prospective et des transition
de l'ADEME 2050 ce qu'on y voit c'est
que pour atteindre cet objectif de
neutralité carbone qui est vraiment
fondamentale sans quoi on remet pas on
n'arrivera pas à stabiliser les choses
sur le plan du durée de changement
climatique et bien on a un gros effort
de sobriété à faire ça a été dit je
crois bien expliquer on a un effort
important aussi de développement de la
production des carbonée d'électricité
avec des renouvelables avec du nucléaire
c'est aujourd'hui au cœur des
discussions les proportions sont au cœur
de discussion de la PPE dans tous les
cas il nous faudra développer de manière
assez considérable d'ici 2050 les
énergies renouvelables parce que
effectivement comme ça a été très bien
dit même si on baisse grâce à la
sobriété un peu notre consommation
d'énergie on va devoir effectivement
avoir une proportion d'électricité plus
importante j'ajouterai jusqu'à il y a
deux conditions supplémentaires pour que
on oppose pas comme mais c'était le
thème un peu provocateur de la Réunion
on sobriété et et croissance c'est que
on soit et il veut lui aussi de
l'évoquer sur le sur un registre aussi
de souveraineté je crois vraiment que
que ce sujet aujourd'hui d'être
investigué que dans toutes les démarches
que nous ferons dans tout le soutien que
nous apportons au développement de telle
énergie ou de telle solution et bien on
est toujours ce réflexe de raisonner en
filière on l'a insuffisamment fait
l'éolien en est le plus bel exemple et
aujourd'hui je crois qu'une grande
partie des difficultés d'acceptation
locale que nous rencontrons sur éolien
c'est lié aussi au fait qu'il n'y a pas
de champion nationaux dans dans cette
sur cette énergie là et et qu'on a bien
du mal à écouter vous l'avez
dit Monsieur Avignon vous a entendu vous
vouliez rajouter un point rapidement
parce que la dernière condition c'est
celle de la solidarité c'est que les
transitions que nous avons accomplir
elles ne doivent jamais oublier les plus
modestes de de nos concitoyens sans quoi
effectivement et bien on va aller vers
des difficultés vers de nouveaux
épisodes sociaux difficiles alors écoute
je débat est très intéressant mais pour
conclure pour que les téléspectateurs
soient bien au courant est-ce que vous
diriez que
sobriété aujourd'hui c'est une
opportunité pour justement cette
croissance verte réguler sans atteinte
écologique en préservant l'environnement
ou finalement il y a aussi
une part un peu d'hypocrisie et que
c'est un fané pour une décroissance pour
certains je commence par vous Olivier
lionzyme sobriété ira avec le
développement de notre outil productif
et donc sans doute avec de la croissance
est-ce que c'est quantifiable ou pas je
pense que c'est beaucoup trop tôt et le
deuxième élément que ça apportera outre
de la souveraineté qui a été évoquée
c'est qu'un outil productif ça
s'installe dans les territoires auprès
des villes moyennes et ça nous permettra
de baisser un petit peu l'intensité de
ce que j'appelle le poison de la
division qui a été nourri par notre
économie très tertiaire avec une
concentration de la richesse dans les
métropoles aux dépenses des territoires
et nous avons besoin de cette cohésion
territoriale comme système social pour
faire face aux défis qui sont les nôtres
qui soient ceux de la souveraineté ou
ceux de la transition écologique qui
coûtera beaucoup d'investissements
beaucoup d'efforts économiques mais
aussi l'effort de changer nos habitudes
il y aura pas que des solutions
technologiques que l'industrie apportera
mais aussi des changements de
comportement que nous devons faire merci
Monsieur alors Hélène pesquine là-dessus
oui moi je suis un peu gêné de ce débat
autour de la croissance qui interne
aujourd'hui enfin en tout cas une
quantité qu'on mesure à partir des
consommations aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
décorer les croissants c'est
consommation or on peut imaginer un
développement alternatif qui peut-être
s'appellera croissance mais enfin en
tout cas qui pourrait être prospère
créer des emplois et créer des richesses
sans être systématiquement corrélés à
des consommations qui elles peuvent être
néfastes finalement on l'a dit pour
l'environnement mais aussi pour les
inégalités au sein de la société je
voudrais donner un exemple très concret
parce qu'on en a finalement donné assez
peu de sobriété heureuse j'allais dire
en tout cas sur lesquels on a trouvé des
alternatives qui effectivement devront
être financés c'est la question de la
sobriété en sol la sobriété foncière
pour lutter contre l'étalement urbain et
et notamment la disparition de la
biodiversité ou des espaces agricoles
autour des villes on sait qu'il existe
des alternatives à l'étalement Lambin
c'est la reconstruction de la ville sur
elle-même c'est de réinvestir des
friches quand elles sont déjà
artificialisées c'est-à-dire déjà occupé
par des fonctions urbaines mais qui sont
des affectées c'est éventuellement
augmenter la densité de l'habitat c'est
réutiliser des logements vacants etc et
là on voit bien qu'on a des solutions
qui sont qui existent déjà qui sont
d'ailleurs créatrices d'emploi qui sont
créatives même et qui évidemment qui ont
un coût supplémentaire mais qui ne
génère pas de contraintes de difficultés
à être réalisées et donc je pense qu'on
a ça revient quand même à la notion de
récit mais on a besoin de représentation
de ces alternatives qui sont quand même
de la croissance ou du développement
c'est du développement urbain sur
lui-même mais malgré tout c'est de la
sobriété puisque on étalera pas sur des
espaces naturels des constructions
nouvelles donc là encore je j'appelle en
avoir une idée beaucoup plus concrète de
ce qu'est cette sobriété dans tous les
enjeux de sobriété devant lesquels on
est merci écoutez c'est un débat fort
intéressant je rappelle une brève
bibliographie alors le plus casse vous
avez publié dans le cadre un petit peu
de cette émission quand la métropole
cesse de s'étaler et ce qui ne dit un
mot là-dessus c'est oui mais ça résonne
avec ce que je disais à l'instant
puisque c'est justement un recueil sur
les alternatives à l'état urbain
c'est-à-dire un récit de la manière dont
on peut mieux marier l'agriculture et la
ville notamment et transformer la ville
sur elle-même sans perdre des
opportunités de développement alors sur
la décroissance il y a de très nombreux
ouvrages on donne deux à ancien un
récent Serge Latouche le pari de la
décroissance bon c'est un classique pour
ceux qui s'intéressent à ce sujet et
plus actuel de Timothée Paris
ralentir ou périr
qui vient d'être publiée au seuil ça
vous intéresse le Gallois de prendre
des pages vous l'offrir non pas pour
vous convertir je ne vais pas vous
convertir la dessus mais bon je voudrais
signaler aussi
Olivier lui Enzy vous avez publié vers
la renaissance industrielle édition
Marie vous pouvez dire un mot cette
renaissance industrielle parce qu'on
parle que de désindustrialisation vous
c'est quoi cette renaissance
industrielle vous la constatez alors
d'abord il y a quelques éléments qu'on a
indiqué oui on a commencé à la constater
oui la crise de l'énergie risque de
casser un petit peu la dynamique c'est
un des risques on est dans une économie
ouverte avec une concurrence notamment
de nos amis américains aujourd'hui qui
ont pris des modèles sur le carbone
différents des nôtres en terme
économique et la renaissance
industrielle était liée à plusieurs
idées d'abord on n'a pas appelé ça une
révolution parce qu'on est convaincu que
réussir cette réindustrialisation il
faut à la fois les nouvelles techniques
et les nouveaux outils digitaux et
environnementaux des nouvelles
générations et toute l'expérience
acquise produire quelque chose c'est 50%
de sa voix 50% de savoir-faire c'est pas
une révolution c'est une continuité
fondée sur les savoirs et qui va
transformer notre type auditif au
service d'un nouveau projet de société
merci infiniment alors je voudrais
remercier Monsieur Boris Ravignon merci
d'avoir été avec nous depuis cette très
belle Ville de Charleville-Mézières et
cette place majestueuse voyez que on
peut aller dans le Grand Est voir du
territoire et du patrimoine merci merci
Madame Pompili d'avoir été avec nous
merci Hélène pesquine merci Louis
Gallois merci Olivier luizet précisé
juste que l'ouvrage a été co-écrit avec
Anaïs vegillis voilà merci donc merci à
l'équipe de LCP d'avoir permis la de
cette émission je rappelle que nous
aurons l'occasion
d'aller plus loin parce que c'est une
question centrale aujourd'hui que tout
le monde sur laquelle tout le monde
s'interroge en se demandant comment y
arriver et qu'est-ce qu'il est possible
de faire et je crois que la narration
qui a été fournie ce récit national que
nous avons apporté modeste pierre à ce
récit et avant de nous quitter je
voudrais vous suggérer cette pensée il
est impossible de réduire sérieusement
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sans une discussion sur la sobriété
énergétique c'est de notre économiste
prix Nobel Esther Duflot
[Musique]